have you decided to stop your membership
with Costco due to what just happened
you know I have not decided to stop my
membership at Costco because I
understand that they they can revoke my
membership if they want to but I'm going
to continue giving them business because
they've got the plug on a few different
products I need and I kind of need to go
there for those products I might try to
find a way to replace those products but
you know quite frankly at the end of the
day I handled myself poorly the manager
Tyson handled himself poorly we were
bumping heads and nobody was a cupcake
in this situation so that being said
I'll walk in there when they stop having
this mask policy and I'll begin shopping
there again so you're gonna go back to
Costco yeah but they have to disrupt
this mask policy I'm not trying to
create like whatever they don't reach in
what if they don't you're gonna send
your girlfriend to go shop and instead
of you the mask no it's it's it's over
man it's over and actually as a matter
of fact I want to start a whole eff
Costco support small business sort of a
thing because man all these big-box
stores are just just raking it in
ranking it and raking it in a small
businessman wording for three months now
so I think when things start opening
back up we need to look at a situation
like this and say hey we got a support
small business we got to stop supporting
these big-box stores as much because
middle-class America is going down and
they're going down fast
there was no bailout for us there were
small business loans which just puts
business owners further in debt but we
didn't get golden parachutes and
bailouts and even Jeff Bezos got a
bailout and his company was killing it
so you know I think that you know this
just needs to open up a discussion as
like whether we want to continue being
patrons at a place like Costco I don't
believe they're calculus I believe
they're crony capitalists that's well
but if you're gonna go back to them
you're saying that you're okay with what
they're doing so if you're gonna make a
statement
you got to revoke your relationship with
them and your membership for you to have
some kind of credibility behind your
voice you can't say I
like the fact that you make me wore a
mess but can I please come and buy that
milk that's discounters for seven bucks
you know you got it you got it if you're
gonna do it you got to take a stand one
of those two places but what I won't
know you I'm gonna take a stand right
now let me go grab some scissors hold on
let's see what you got oh my gosh Costco
is gonna contact this and say why did
you make us lose a customer man we
wanted this Costco Kevin back
all right I'm back man I got some
scissors okay what you gonna do in
Costco kids Patrick all right where is
this stupid card out I'm surprised that
I throw it out the window on my way home
here's Costco okay here's my Costco card
you see hard right yes all right let's
just see if I can't there we go so it's
official for you now we broke up baby up
here I calm people people are like you
need to shop at Sam's Club instead maybe
I'm gonna take your recommendation there
it is there it is
[Music]